you think that there's Merit to being
aware and living consciously and present
rather than potentially your brain
solving other issues in the future or
thinking about past events and stuff
like that yeah yeah and I also think
that it's uh it's very generous to
assume that we're all up in our heads
solving problems I I don't think that's
what happens I think we're just kind of
killing time I mean it's it's a cliche
sort of thing to complain about but it
is we've all like you know um I was
somewhere recently maybe the dentist or
something and we're waiting in
line and you look around in a waiting
room for example and you look around and
like everybody is just looking at their
phone you know and and it used to be
that in that situation maybe you have a
magazine or something most people are
you're just like sitting there